.
OUR BEST TD YOUR FAMIL
>> THANK YOU>>> AS COLORADO SPRI
PO SAITODAT 17EOFFEREDUNSHOTNIG
SHOT SEVEN TIMES.
SO BARRETT, FIRST OF
ARE YOU E DO THINGTH
I DID NOT EXPECT T IT.I T PESO I
VE AO OR
REHABILITATION THIN
WANED INSIDE THE
>>AD BEEN E BEFORE.
UT TRYIVYOU GUYSN  A,  IN THE C.
I HAVE H
YOU KNOW, WHEN PEOPLE DO PARTIES
AND STLE WILL .D OF SOUNDS LIKEA
LIKE A LO BULY OVE
AS P, ANEN S
I LOOKED T RIG
THE NMAN, A DOOR H
THNM MT IN MAND THAT'SNOW, I'M
I ACTUALLY -- YOK OFF I'ON MEDI.
RUNNG.
.
I KNEW GFEOW PROCEEDED TO SHOOT.
MEHAD BEEN SN TIMES, OR
GRAZE
DON'T KNOW.R
I RAN OU TO 30 YARDS, N  FF OFR
COLLAPSEES.PP T
COMPLE BECAUSE THEY
IFRVERYTHY STARTECOUNTING BULL
DO WALKING.AUSE -- ME ANREIKRII.
ANY, , AND P CD  CONIV
AND I DON'T KNOW WHY I'M STI
HERE GLAD TO
.ORE S ET
THAT CONVERSION WITHR DAD
I LOVED  VED  I'DN SH, SOMEBOK E
STD ANI G
AND THLAE 20,
ANDID,UTES TO GET THEM.DI
AND N SONCES THAT PASSED B.BODYA
TAKE ME IN ALLTH. FIRE.
AND THENLY CSEE ME EARERHO, YOU
PEO KNOWHERERECOVERING
CTE WORST D D  HUTF D WITH
THINAT EMEES, SO IF ER
HELP THEM
IN ANYN I FEELLIKE I DID GOOD,
ME SITTING , ALWAYS
FOTHP HALFL, NOT HA ED N'R LOOK
AT,
OR AATAS
CHANGED IN THE LAST 48.
,  SAY YOUSMILIS FEEL
U
SMILING.
IT'S GOING TO BE A